After reviewing 20 years of research,...
...a scientist from Bristol University has concluded that chickens are smarter than human toddlers.
Skills including numeracy and self-control...
...are among those in which chickens show mastery,...
...whereas humans don't get the hang of them until about their fourth year.
It's not just any chickens, by the way.
Freshly hatched chicks show that they can track up to five numbers...
...by consistently picking the group of plastic eggs with a larger number...
...even after the egg groupings were moved around.
In the review, it was also learned that not only do chickens excel at math,...
...they show promise in the area of structural engineering.
In other words, the test chicks were more interested in diagrams of objects...
...that were structurally feasible rather than those that were physically impossible.
Several of the studies also showed young chickens were capable of both empathy and showing self-control,...
...two additional abilities not present in toddlers until around four.
This isn't to say that chickens are any better than toddlers,...
...just that it appears chicks are a lot more complex than most think.